congratulations on this guys explain to
me your relationship on the show what
can you tell me what can you notice
we've been doing this we feel so bad
you can't say anything uh we meet in the
first episode in the first episode i'll
ask for your facebook that's my favorite
and you give it to me and then i give it
to you and i throw it it's really it's
cute it's like a little cute it's a meat
cube i think that people will be rooting
for for the uh
i'm sure they will even just in the
little bit that i saw i think so there's
a little something there right a little
samsung she's only like fourteen yeah
yeah we don't we don't we don't condone
that creep i know it is that world
though it's not me i wouldn't no i mean
i wouldn't
although i did say there was a scene
that you had with matt's yeah at the
beginning yeah it seems like when aaron
damon have
attention there's attention a little bit
yeah and knowing the family history from
game of thrones yeah that's a little
incestuous is there a romantic tension
between rene and damon does it shift
once the gold is thrown down at the end
of this episode where she's now the
successor yeah i think ultimately damon
rainier's relationship is about power
and that's where it's really interesting
because we see the way that she asserts
her power he is questioned as air and
then the way that he gets back at her in
like little there's just like very
subtle little jobs so they're both
trying to one-up each other and it's a
very unspoken relationship which which
is what makes it kind of so exciting to
play do you think the realm will ever
accept me as that queen a woman would
not inherit the iron throne because that
is the order of things yes you're
playing the the younger version of this
character what kind of queen do you
think that she would grow up to be i
don't even know what happens i haven't
read all the scripts i wasn't given them
yeah but i think she would be hypothesis
hypothesis i think a very empathetic
queen i think she would be someone who
would really be willing to do the wrong
thing to make the right choice but your
character seems like a little bit of a
mystery what can you tell me about your
character i can tell you that he has an
alliterative name
um
much like yourself much like myself look
at something i was waiting for together
he is of dornish descent and the only
you know dornish character we meet in
the first episode so i think that that
plays a massive uh part in sort of like
you know watching the original show and
the way that the dornish characters were
looked upon and spoken about so i think
he's an outsider from the get-go and i
think that that uh gives him um
something seems like a little bit of a
badass yeah he is a bit of a badass
actually he's an underdog yeah he's a
bit of an underdog and i think like
especially when you've got characters
like damon targaryen and you know those
guys who are all sort of loud and
outspoken and you've got someone who's
quite quiet and his actions speak for
him rather than like his you know he's
not an eloquent man in the same way that
some of the other characters are because
of their upbringings so how familiar
with the original series were you guys i
hadn't watched it until i booked it i
hadn't seen it i see i i loved i loved
the original show when you met with the
team we like guys whatever we do we've
got to stick the landing yeah better
than the last episode yes of the
original series the original series was
amazing and like you know i think that
we'll be lucky if we even touch the
surface of how great that show was
knowing like how passionate fans were
about that first series are you guys
ready for that level of passion to
follow you into your lives no no no no
no no definitely not nope and not
completely underprivileged
overwhelmed overwhelmed and unprepared
basically yeah is it a surreal moment
when you find yourself you know standing
on one of these sets in the full costume
you're like this is it man this is like
i'm doing this we're doing a game of
thrones show we yeah it was pretty
surreal for us we definitely on offer we
met up for a walk and many drinks we're
just both geeked out like kind of like
wow game of thrones this is kind of
weird crazy it's hard to at point
sometimes enjoy it because it's just
like happening in front of you and it's
so overwhelming but you i don't know i'm
just kind of reminding myself that it
could never get better than this so just
just a joke yeah
your family has dragons
there are power men should never have
trifled with
believe either of you both of you had
your own personal dragon what would you
name your dragon
zorro
that's a cool name
yeah
my brother and i's favorite film ever is
gilbert
[Music]